على ان للعوده مراسله فرانس 24 في القدس
همم صباح الخير الليله واهلا بك نتحدث معك
عن هذه الحصيله الجديده ومقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين في هذه في هذه المدهمه
الاسرائيليه الجديده لجنين ومخيمها في
سياق السياسيه طبعا جديد واعلانات
اقتحام للمدينه والمخيم هذا الاقتحام تم
همم بالف الفجر
وباعداد كبيره وفقا لشهود عياننا فلسطينيه
الثلاثه بحسب الشهود عيان احد من اكد
الروايه التي الفلسطينيه التي سنسدها قال
بانها
عينيه قال بان جنود اسرائيليين ترجلوا كان
هناك يتواجد في المنطقه شبين وبداوا
باطلاق النار عليهما حتى في وصفه قال بان
اطلاق النار باتجاه هناك بشكل كثيف جدا
الى درجه
بشكل كبير ومنظر قوي جدا هذا حسب شهد
العيان الفلسطيني وقال بان الشاب الثالث
التي تم التي تم استهدافه كان ذاهب الى
عمله و اا لم يكن يشارك في المواجهات او
لم يكن من ضمن من يستهدف ولكن عندما شاهده
الجنود اطلقوا النار باتجاهه الامر الذي
ادى الى ارتقائه واصبح عدد من يرتقه في
جنين فجر هذا اليوم 3 من الفلسطينيين
بطبيعه الحال هذه العمليه بحسب الجيش
الاسرائيلي تندرج في اطار عمليات الاقتحام
من اجل الاعتقال الفلسطينيين يقال بانهم
من ضمن المطلوبين للجيش الاسرائيلي
وبتبيعه الحال جنين في حاله همم استنفار
الان يتم الاستعداد لتشييع اجى تميمنا من
قتلوا هناك اعلان للحداد قبل همم خروجنا
في هذا البث ايضا كان هناك توتر عند
الحاجه الزرقاء الفاصل ما بين القدس
ومدينه رام الله تم اغلاق الحاجز الاكثر
من 30 دقيقه واعيد فتحه قبل قليل وهمم
هناك
حب
التوتر في الوضع على اعتبار ان في كل
اقتحام او في كل مواجهه اسرائيليه يزداد
عدد من يتم استهدافهما يقتل من قبل
الفلسطينيين اصبح العدد يرتفع ما بين
ثلاثه وحتى في 72 ساعه في الايام القادمه